Scar is one of Disney's most memorable villains,
but the 2019 Lion King movie has changed some
crucial details about the evil lion's origins
and story.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining the new secret history
of Scar that's revealed in The Lion King remake.
Plus I'll tell you how the new movie addresses
a long-standing fan theory that Scar and Mufasa
aren't actually brothers.
Some spoilers, so take care if you haven't
seen it yet.
Don't forget my giveaway is running, so be
sure to subscribe and let me know your thoughts
about Scar for a chance to win.
The origin of Scar's name and how he received
the wound on his eye were never addressed
in the classic movie.
However, there's a vital addition to the remake's
version of the following scene:
"Perhaps you shouldn't turn your back on me."
"Is that a challenge?"
"Temper, temper.
I wouldn't dream of challenging you."
In the 2019 version, Scar says "I wouldn't
dream of challenging you again" meaning that
there's already been a confrontation between
the two lions in the past.
And I think the new film hints that it was
during this previous challenge that Mufasa
gave Scar the signature wound across his left
eye.
For example, in the reworked story, when Mufasa
begs his brother for help during the stampede,
Scar viciously slashes him across the eye
which sends Mufasa plunging to his death in
the gorge below.
This is a change to the traditional animation
where Scar flings Mufasa off the cliff.
By adding the face slash in the remake, it
suggests that the villainous lion is taking
revenge in kind for the scar Mufasa gave him.
Now, what's also interesting about this change
is that it seems to invalidate the backstory
given to Scar in a book series that was a
spin-off from the classic film.
The first story of that series, "A Tale of
Two Brothers", recounted that Scar was originally
called Taka and that he changed his name to
Scar after getting into a scrape with a buffalo
that slashed him across the eye with his horns.
Although that book series was authorised by
Disney, it's not entirely clear whether it's
ever been canon as elements from it don't
fit with the animated Lion King sequel.
Either way the 2019 movie suggests a brand
new origin for Scar's signature wound.
Another change in the remake that's quite
likely related to that fateful challenge between
Scar and Mufasa is Scar's new backstory with
Sarabi, who was Mufasa's queen of the Pride
Lands.
In the new movie, a subplot involving romantic
jealousy has been added to Scar's origins,
and the first hint comes at the beginning
of the new story when Scar says to Mufasa
and Zazu, "As you know I have tremendous respect
for the queen."
In fact, in the novelization of the new Lion
King film, when Scar says that line it triggers
an intense anger in Mufasa.
This indicates that Mufasa and Scar's rivalry
over Sarabi has been stewing for some time.
And it also reveals that, as well as wanting
to rule the Pride Lands, there was an additional
motive behind Scar's personal feud with Mufasa.
Later, after Scar takes over as king, Sarabi
accuses him of overhunting, at which point
he reveals "long ago you chose Mufasa over
me, but now there is a new king."
With Mufasa gone, Scar now requests that she
join him as queen.
That new dialogue reminds me of a deleted
scene from the 1994 movie where Scar was wondering
why his subjects don't look up to him like
they did his brother:
"I'm sick to death of him.
What did he have that I don't have?"
"Adoring subjects, respect of your species,
a loving family, a devoted queen, shall I
go on sire?"
In the remake, Scar realises that he's unloved
by the rest of the pride and believes that,
if he can make Sarabi his partner, then he'll
gain the respect she has from the other lions.
"Yes I need a queen.
She would rule by side.
We'll have cubs, little Scars running all
over the place."
In the deleted scene from 1994, Scar actually
proposes to Nala rather than Sarabi.
Like Simba's mother, Nala also refused, and
Scar responded by threatening her.
"Nala, Nala, Nala..
You know you really have no choice.
One way or another I always get what I want.
Either be my queen or be forever banished
from the Pride Lands."
Scar's creepy threats in the animated movie
were also going to be one of the reasons that
Nala decided to leave Pride Rock to look for
help.
And there's another nod to that deleted scene
in a brand new scene for Nala in the remake,
where she has to sneak around Scar and the
hyenas before she can get away.
Another change to Scar's backstory is that
in the new version, he doesn't team up with
the hyenas before his visit to the elephant
graveyard.
Now when Scar arrives, it's clear there isn't
an alliance between them yet as they even
threaten to eat him.
This is quite different to the first movie
where the hyenas are obviously on familiar
terms with Scar.
"Oh Scar, it's just you."
"We were afraid it was somebody important."
"I mean, you're one of us.
I mean, you're our pal."
He even brings them fresh meat to eat.
"I don't think you really deserve this.
I practically gift-wrapped those cubs for
you."
Given Scar's lack of familiarity with the
hyenas in the CG reboot, it seems like his
plan to send Simba to the elephant graveyard
wasn't something pre-arranged with them.
He was simply hoping to take advantage of
the hyenas' natural behaviour and that they'd
kill and eat the young cub of their own accord.
There's an interesting change to how Scar
guilt-trips Simba about Mufasa's death in
the remake.
This time Scar takes Simba into the gorge
specifically under the pretext that the little
cub needs to practise his roar.
"This gorge is where all lions come to find
their roar."
"Watch this!"
"You'll get it Simba.
Just takes time."
"Dad will be so proud, won't he?"
"It's a gift he'll never forget."
By contrast, in the 1994 classic, Scar tells
Simba to wait there for a "marvellous surprise"
from his father.
"Oooh, What is it?"
"If I told you, it wouldn't be a surprise
now, would it?"
and, rather deviously, only mentions practising
his roar as a throwaway line, in passing.
"And just between us, you might want to work
on that little roar of yours, hmm?"
However, in the new movie, Scar deliberately
and clearly links Simba's roar with his father.
"Even Mufasa came here when he was your age.
Refused to leave until his roar could be heard
above the rim."
Which firmly plants the seed in the young
lion's mind that practising his roar led to
his dad's death.
That makes Simba feel even guiltier later
when he thinks his father died trying to save
him.
And when Scar arrives to find the poor little
cub grieving over his dead father, in the
remake the villain twists the knife even further
with some brand new lines that weren't in
the animated movie.
Scar says to Simba, "Your father had such
hopes for you, gave you so many chances.
And this is how you repay him."
Then after asking the young cub "What will
your mother think?",
in the new version, Scar also tells Simba,
he's
"A son who causes his father's death.
A boy who kills a king."
Something that's confused Lion King fans for
many years is a theory that claims Scar and
Mufasa might not really be brothers.
I think the new movie gives its own answer
to that question, but just before we get into
that, we need to review the evidence for why
Scar and Mufasa might not be related by blood.
The moment from the 1994 movie used to support
that theory is when Scar compares his intellectual
and physical capabilities with Mufasa's.
"Well, as far as brains go, I got the lion's
share.
But when it comes to brute strength, I'm afraid
I'm at the shallow end of the gene pool."
The theory claims that what Scar's really
saying is that he and Mufasa aren't genetically
related.
When it comes to the theory, there have been
some conflicting attempts by the animation's
filmmakers to clarify the situation.
In a 2017 interview with Hello Giggles, producer
Don Hahn said, "[While making the movie] we
talked about the fact that it was very likely
[Scar and Mufasa] would not have both the
same parents.
Occasionally there are prides that do have
two male lions, [but] they're not equals.
One lion will always kind of be off in the
shadows.
We were trying to use those animal truths
to underpin the story so we sort of figured
Scar and Mufasa couldn't really be from the
same gene pool."
But while Hahn heavily implied Scar and Mufasa
weren't brothers, to add to the confusion,
a couple of weeks later, The Lion King's director
Rob Minkoff told Screen Junkies the exact
opposite, saying that he wanted to clear up
that Scar and Mufasa were in fact brothers.
Despite all that, the 2019 movie seems to
take a few steps to provide more clarity.
First of all, Scar's "shallow end of the gene
pool" line has been replaced
and he now says "when it comes to brute strength,
I'm afraid my big brother will always rule."
So, the original line which seemed to trigger
the theory has been scrapped and substituted
with Scar specifically calling Mufasa his
"big brother".
On top of that, there's another change at
the end of the new film.
Just after Scar confesses to Simba that he
killed Mufasa, a new line has been added where
Simba asks him, "your own brother, how could
you?"
The emphasis on this new line implies that
Simba is completely outraged because he views
Scar's murder of Mufasa as even more heinous
as the two lions were related.
Disney also used the opportunity of remaking
The Lion King to fix a number of other mistakes
and confusing moments in the classic movie.
You can learn all about those in my other
video.
Tap the screen to watch that or click the
link in the video description.
Now, what do you think about the new Scar
and the changes to the villain's story?
Let me know in the comments below and subscribe
to enter my Lion King giveaway!
Next, tap left for my full comparison of the
two Lion King movies or tap right for another
video you're sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this, a like and a share
are always hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!